we're back the most men and I are
combining forces for our biggest season
yet and we're calling it Burger bucket
list let's do this let's go some of the
best burgers I've ever had in my life
have been with you guys I think I've
developed a burger that NASA could use
crazy for National Burger month we're
chasing our Burger dreams out on the
open road going back to where it all
started
people need to come here and eat this
and know where it came from man that
smells so good this burger has now been
replicated all over the globe
holy crap this is a power of lunch
a trip through the cosmos we're sending
Burgers to space hey look astrophysicist
Neil deGrasse Tyson I'm not liking
mutton chops I used to have those there
you go when they were in style
new Burgers that'll make you say wow now
I know why you do that have you tried
this a burger Omakase that will blow
your mind this is my favorite afternoon
right now we're gonna bring out the
Sears all wow wow wow wow wow tracking
down the best of the best right oh my
gosh Burgers
the burger show presents Burger bucket
list with me Alvin kailan and me George
modes let's do this
foreign
hello Internet it's your boy Alvin kylon
make sure you hit that like button smash
that subscribe button ring that
notification Bell if not for me
for the burgers
this show that show him the wine